Lakers unbeaten check unbeaten as they
take group a phoenix uh still in that
hunt at two they make and one come on
man Phoenix plays me at Memphis on
Friday a chance to go to three and one
and keep those Wild Card hopes alive
remember three group champ three three
group winners and one wild card in the
East and one wild card in the west but
your Lakers your Lakers go through their
perfect in group play yeah when you are
when you're playing for something
whatever the prize would be you know we
all tried to play for the championship
that was the prize so the in E season
tournament do have trophy but in
addition that 500,000 second place gets
250 as an athlete when you put your mind
to it and say okay we have to do this in
a short period of time to get it done
Lakers are playing very very focused I I
I wonder if they could play like they
played tonight all the time I'm
concerned about my signs are you I am
because uh Bradley Bill is out out
another three to four weeks we haven't
seen a game that's had Bradley Bill Deon
Booker and Kevin Durant together it came
out the other day he's going to be out
another minimum three weeks and I think
it's scary being in the west because I
don't think any team in the West can win
three Series in a row on the road that's
just my personal opinion and they got to
keep this thing together while bills out
three weeks is a long time in the NBA
and you know it puts tremendous pressure
on Kevin and Devin and like I say you
can't you have to be in just just my
opinion you have to have home court at
least one round and because if you're in
the play in and you have to play against
a great team the first round second
round third round I don't think any team
in the west is good enough to win four
straight uh excuse me three straight
game series on the road because the West
is just too loaded yeah they go to eight
and six with their win tonight what do
you think about Phoenix and and really
are um the fact that we just haven't
seen what we wanted to see at this point
how these how these three would work
together well interestingly enough I
don't think we even seen Kevin
Durant as a Phoenix Sun how they
expected cuz every year there's been
injuries there's been something within
the team that hasn't allowed them to be
who they are with Kevin Durant so we're
still I I have no idea what this team is
going to look like I don't know why they
going to how they're going to implement
Bill we because that was always a
question mark is he going to be the
point is he going to be more of a two
when you're going to have Devon Booker
then you had last year Booker was hurt
Chris Paul like all of these different
variables I've never seen the Phoenix
Suns as the Phoenix Sun yeah and it's
going to be interesting Kenny
because what when you bring all this
Talent together number one they haven't
been there already they're out another 3
weeks and when you break them together
it's going to be a learn in process
because who's going to play the point
yeah and like like and uh so it's it's
it's not as going to be as easy people
think when you bring I got to give a
shout out too Ernie okay I got to give
out no I gotta give a shout out on took
a hard no I want to give a shout
out this guy is one of my favorite
players ever and he's one of my favorite
people I want to give a shout out to
Russell Westbrook yeah who says hey hey
this thing ain't going to work we talked
about it last week it ain't going to
work and he is confident enough got
enough self-esteem like you know what
I'll come off the bench for a guy who
has won MVP who's going to be in the
Hall of Fame man I just want I I love
that guy as a player and I want to give
him a shout out for being selfless uh we
mentioned the scoring charts and Kevin
Durant continuing to climb and passing
Elvin Hazen so here's a look at uh uh
Moses in line for him yeah on your shout
out to B I miss you Dad you w the best
ever